when all of that goes down you get cast
in this big franchise and then they have
to cut your scene
you had already had a significant amount
of experience so are you able to tap
into like the business end of your brain
and tell yourself like that's not my
fault that's just the way the industry
works or
is there disappointment there that needs
to be managed and move
beyond honestly like
whatever's the best thing for the film
because at the end of the day i'd rather
have had the experience
of being in a really good film than be
in a film for the sake of
being in it like if it doesn't work like
you don't want to be in something and
then be the sore thumb that sticks out
um and i didn't feel that way at all and
the russo brothers didn't feel that way
at all but
you know we did this incredibly this
very like sentimental scene and
something that was really beautiful and
a gift to the fans i think um which is
why they
they had it included and then why they
essentially released it
is because for the fans who really love
marvel like it was a nice little
extra soft soft little delectable thing
for them to kind of
digest but um you know with it's a lot
it's
very end of the movie and it didn't
really make sense and they texted me and
i talked with other people and i was
like yeah like honestly like whatever is
the best thing for the film at the end
of the day
um yeah i guess
somehow i feel like you almost like got
the best of
both worlds like you're still part of it
you gave the fandom something that they
really wanted
and you know you you did the the smart
thing and you said whatever's best for
the film
yeah well i i hope i'm i i'm glad
the people who wanted to see it and
really ask to see it got to see it
um and for me yeah to i mean to be on
that kind of film like
the experience is honestly that's the
number one takeaway is being able to do
[Applause]
that
you